I need to know who do you think is going
to replace Michael Strahan on live with
Kelly and much a good question and I
don't know cuz I was even thinking of
when when Michael Strahan was
auditioning and like Neil Patrick Harris
was there and um Jerry O'Connell i think
but there's so many great people i think
they're gonna do like a whole brand-new
sir you think so yes now like lately in
the past couple days there's been this
Anderson Cooper uproar because when he
was asked about it by andy cohen on
watch what happens live he didn't say no
he said i'd love to be with kelly but
nobody's offered anything yet what do
you think about Anderson well he's great
he's great every time he's on the show
but I don't know you know I think
Michael just brought a different just
brought a different crowd and so I love
him he's so fun and energetic um I don't
know I think they I think Anderson's
great but I don't think he's right for
every day do you think they might do
another one big I don't know is it to
Kathie Lee and Hoda oh well you know
what you know what I mean I didn't think
about that that's smart I don't think
about that has this been kind of the hub
of over at ACC are people talking about
it or you all just going about your
business oh we talked about it trust me
we were all talking about it listen
they're both so great Kelly's awesome i
love watching her Michaels one of my
favorite memek said i'll still get to
see him on GMA and you know Kelly their
shows in the same building as we
understand my wing with her are you
kidding